the movies The Legend of Tarzan it hits
theaters coming up this Friday Samuel
Jackson one of the stars of the movies
and he was honored on Sunday night the
Beatty awards for 40 years of big-screen
badassery the legendary actor was
presented with the ceremony's lifetime
achievement award by Spike Lee who
called him one of the greatest actors on
this God's planet and the
hardest-working man in show business
Samuel Jackson joining us Sam how are
you this morning
that's was it more than that no it's way
less than that now what a minute I was
in the movie business when I was 20 some
years old I didn't get into movie
business till I was almost 50 when did
you become a badass though I don't know
um I guess sometime around pulp fiction
like 20 years ago
yeah do you still have the wallet from
pulp fiction I never had it Quentin
always did Quentin had one and the prop
guy had another one I've been given a
couple of them since then I never had I
never had the one that was actually in
the movie Quentin at it what sports do
you want talk sports sure you want
what's on your mind what's what sports
related that's bothering you or you're
inspired by don't bother me I'm looking
forward to the Olympics
kind of watching see if Serena's gonna
you know when a major this year after
all these losses you know kind of paying
attention to one balloon in that way
looking forward to football season all
those things who's your general I'm
looking forward to major stuff you know
baseball season too long for me to keep
up with so sometime around playoff time
I'll start painting the baseball
who's your football team um
the Falcons until you know sometime
around midseason somebody else watching
cheer for what kind of athlete will you
enjoy the game what kind of athlete a
decent athlete um I ran track in high
school I was a hurdler sprinter and in
college that was on this one
Dean for a minute you know but decent
athlete I play recreational basketball
never was good enough to you know play
on anybody's team organized ball but I
enjoy sports and I'm a decent golfer I
know you love it but who is the athlete
where you all of a sudden you you said
that's that's who I'd like to be or I'd
like to do that oh I don't think I was
ever that kind of athlete not that I am
either Sam by I thought that everybody
wanted to be Ali you know Ali was
everybody died you know at a certain
point because he actually represented so
much during a time when I was a young
man you know in terms of politics
athletic ability charisma you know so he
was the ideal but there's no way you
could be that you know I couldn't anyway
but he was the ideal you know if you had
to choose more when you look at these
athletes now and it feels like
everybody's an imitator of Ollie you
know obviously to a lesser degree but
when it was happening in real time with
Ollie we didn't know what to make of it
now you feel like these guys that it
sort of orchestrated when they try to do
something close you know people in the
media or the dominant dominant culture
didn't know what to make of it and you
know black people and young black men I
never played a game in my life where we
didn't talk to and I walked out of house
with my first bag of marble people start
telling me how they were gonna beat me
and take my marbles and I had to talk
too much you know we even talked smack
and you know hide-and-seek there was
like okay somebody who speaks that
language you're right I didn't know how
to process it and that's why I think
most of white America like Joe Frazier
because they understood Joe Frazier more
than they did Muhammad Ali and Joe
Frazier Ali did but they thought he was
humble because you know he didn't he
didn't he didn't talk this loud or he
wasn't as quick on his feet as Ali we we
gave a little more March Madness field
to your movies by the way we we we we
were seeding movies that you were in not
not you
role in it but the movies okay so we we
had some trouble here with the number
one seed there was some argument some
good debate here okay it was between
Goodfellas and pulp fiction now this
isn't your role it's the movie itself
now I write I fought for pulp fiction I
think it's a far better movie than
Goodfellas you have a small role in
Goodfellas but once again it's not about
your role it's about the movie so we
went okay
Goodfellas was a number one seed then
pulp fiction then it was do the right
thing true romance coming to America
Jurassic Park jungle fever die hard I
would have been just one than that yeah
that's your innate seed at diner
oh no deep blue thing well we did if
there's a 16-team bracket then yes it's
in there because I love seeing you get
eaten by a shark but how do you act it's
not every day that you go okay I'm I'm
gonna get eaten by a shark like how do
you prepare for the movie that you're
gonna get eaten by a dinosaur or a shark
well Renny told me that was going to
happen so I was I was looking forward to
that and you know in in Jurassic I was
actually supposed to go to Hawaii and
shoot that scene but there was like a
storm went through there and destroyed
the set so I never got to go to Hawaii I
didn't get to run from the Velociraptor
and do all the stuff I needed to do
there to show my arm hanging somewhere I
said I would see that doesn't count
would you what do you think as much as
falling out a window in Star Wars
what do you think our seedings there are
you comfortable with Goodfellas at 1:00
or is pulp fiction should pulp fiction
be one I put Pulp Fiction at one and
maybe Jackie Brown or Django in that you
know and also I mean my favorite movie
that you know should be on that list is
long kids couldn't they
and snakes on a plane the embedded
wealth next on the plane is like that
would be like the sixteenth season we're
talking to a Samuel Jackson the movie is
a legend of tarzan do you want to give
us the synopsis here on on the movie
yeah this is somewhat of an origin story
you get a lot of the origin of cars in
terms of his relationship the ape
community he was raised in and how that
how that transpired he's living in
England when we meet him in this film
and he's encouraged to go back by my
character who's a real historic figures
named George Washington William to
expose King Leopold's atrocities in the
jungle because he's trying to borrow
money from the Queen of England and he's
trying to prevent him from getting that
money and exposing you know slavery and
and the Holocaust that he's creating
there so he convinced his cars and to go
back to help him do that and in the
midst of that you know Jane gets
kidnapped and Charlie becomes Tarzan
again I didn't know that Tarzan's real
name was John Clayton and I always think
of John Clayton from ESPN they're NFL
insider so exactly well then the whole
thing too and we always thought he was
just Lord Greystoke right yeah yeah now
I find out his name is John Clayton the
third there's so many random things that
I read about you did were you an usher
at Martin Luther King Junior's funeral
yes I was well I was a student at
Morehouse College at the time and they
had the funeral on campus so they asked
people to volunteer to help people find
their way when they came to general on
campus though I was one of those people
you're 19 at the time 18 19 you
understand the magnitude I'm sure of it
but but to be able to yeah be an usher
Lina that's that's a rule that was the
day after well actually um Robert Koch
and Bill Cosby actually rented a plane
and we took they flew a bunch of us to
Memphis we marched with the garbage man
the day before and then flew back and
did that the next day
were you in acting at that time yes I
had just started yeah in the theatre
department yeah yeah before I let you go
your thoughts on Pat Summitt I know you
being a tennessean oh man you know how
awesome Pat Summitt was and and and the
amount of pride she brought to the state
of Tennessee and to women's sports in
particular you know she was a hard
taskmaster but a wonderful friend to
those girls a wonderful mentor I met her
a couple of times when I was hosting the
ESPYs and when she would come to the
ESPYs the mark that she made on the game
and the influence of getting women
through loves particular glass ceiling
and creating opportunities for a lot of
coaches women coaches now and setting a
standard will be hard to be beaten by
anyone but thank God she did it and it's
a shame that the end of her life you
know was what it is my mom my mother had
Alzheimer's so I understand that totally
and I understand how our family must
have you know felt going through it and
how I felt watching her and listening to
people talk about it but um she's one in
a million guaranteed you know there are
a lot of things that she did that won't
be surpassed or need to be emulated by a
lot of people a final question could you
beat Tiger Woods in golf right now long
time ago well I might have a shot now
wait wait what when I was like a 16 wait
so he gave you he gained how many shots
did he give you I think I mean almost
like things that okay first time I
played st. Andrews I actually played
with Tigers when the Dunhill Cup is
actually an international competition so
the first day I played I played with him
the second after I played with daily but
the day I played with him he said follow
me I was a 16 a shot 78 he shot even par
I win wow you can hold that above him
forever I do did you play did you play
Jordan play with my construct a few
times but you can beat Chuck yeah does
just Mike talk trash to you woke me up
one morning made me get up in London and
we went out and played together I beat
those guys with the rental club that day
wow look at you
hey great to talk to you good luck with
the movie and thanks for joining us
thank you
all right all right samuel l.jackson the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience